Guatemala es un país que tiene el dudoso honor de
haber sufrido la guerra civil más larga de toda
Latinoamérica: 36 años de conflicto. Hablamos
del país más grande de toda Centroamérica,
al menos en términos de población…
y también uno de los más corruptos.
(Rodeado por Honduras, Belice y
El Salvador de Bukele, Guatemala
es también el país centroamericano
con la mayor frontera con México.
Sumergido de una inmensa naturaleza, además de
con volcanes tan imponentes como el de Pacaya,
el Volcán de Fuego o el de Agua, también
nos encontramos la mayor población indígena
de Centroamérica. Aproximadamente el 40% de
sus 17 millones de habitantes son indígenas,
es decir, hablamos de cerca de 7 millones
de guatemaltecos, lo que lo convierte en
el segundo país de toda Latinoamérica con mayor
población indígena tan solo por detrás de México.)
Pero Guatemala no es solo una rica
naturaleza y una gran diversidad cultural.
Como ya hemos dicho, Guatemala destaca
por ser extremadamente corrupto.
Cómo podéis ver en este ranking, Guatemala es
el quinto país más corrupto de Latinoamérica.
Lo cual les sitúa automáticamente como uno
de los 30 más corruptos del mundo ¡Pero ya
sé lo que me vais a decir todos! Un país
corrupto en Latinoamérica ¡Menuda novedad,
Fonseca! Pues sí, tenéis razón… pero el
caso de Guatemala es especial por una razón:
Guatemala ha hecho un esfuerzo titánico
para luchar contra la corrupción.
De hecho, si hubiéramos hecho este vídeo
hace 4 o 5 años, la historia sería “cómo
Guatemala está dejando atrás su horrible
pasado. Para que os hagáis una idea,
en 2022 registraron su peor dato histórico en
los rankings de corrupción. Dicho de otra forma,
que vamos de Guatemala… a Guatepeor (Lo siento,
no he podido evitar hacer el chiste malo).
¿Pero sabéis qué es lo más curioso? Que
en esta degradación institucional no hay
ningún mesías populista estilo Hugo Chávez
ni similares. Ni siquiera una revolución.
Esta es una historia de intereses
creados, política de salón y mucha,
muchísima impunidad. Así que la
pregunta que hoy nos hacemos es:
¿Cómo demonios llegó Guatemala a ser un
país tan corrupto? ¿Cómo quiso liderar la
lucha contra la corrupción a nivel mundial?
¿Por qué fracasó este experimento? ¿Hasta
dónde llegan realmente los tentáculos de
las coimas, los sobres y los sobornos?
Hoy vamos a responder a estas preguntas,
pero antes, vamos a ver un poco de historia.
T1 (LAS SECUELAS DE UN LARGO CONFLICTO)
Ya sé que usar la expresión “de Guatemala
a Guatepeor” es un chiste malo… pero es que
refleja perfectamente la historia de este país.
Vamos a ser claros: casi todos los países de
Latinoamérica tienen historias turbulentas,
pero pocos llegan al nivel de Guatemala.
Podríamos decir que desde su comienzo
como país, casi todo ha ido mal.
Guatemala se independizó en 1821 de España. Dos
años más tarde, en 1823, se independizaron de
México. Desde entonces, este país ha sufrido
una serie de dictaduras, una tras otra: desde
Rafael Carrera justo después de la independencia
guatemalteca, pasando por Manuel Estrada Cabrera,
el General Jorge Ubico o la dictadura
comenzada por el coronel Carlos Castillo Armas.
Por supuesto, Guatemala también tuvo
una etapa comunista. Hablamos de la
presidencia de JACOBO ARBENZ. Presidencia
que terminó con un golpe de estado apoyado
por Estados Unidos. Ya sabéis que, durante
la guerra fría, América Latina fue el patio
trasero de Washington. Y Guatemala fue
una de las víctimas más damnificadas.
(La llegada en 1954 del gobierno militar
encabezado por Castillo Armas supuso la
abolición de las políticas de izquierdas de Jacobo
Árbenz y Juan José Arévalo. El ejército suprimió
la reforma agraria y la formación de asociaciones
y sindicatos de campesinos y trabajadores.
Apenas 6 años más tarde, en 1960, dio
comienzo la guerra civil que enfrentó al
gobierno militar y las Patrullas de Autodefensa
Civil creadas por este contra varias guerrillas
revolucionarias como la Organización del Pueblo
en Armas o el Ejército Guerrillero de los Pobres,
las cuales más tarde crearon el famoso grupo
Unidad Revolucionaria Nacional Guatemalteca.
El caso es que durante los siguientes 36 años
cerca de 200 mil personas perdieron la vida de
forma violenta. El 83% de todas ellas fueron
indígenas. De hecho, en medio de esta guerra
tuvo lugar incluso un genocidio contra los
indígenas “Maya I’xil” entre 1981 y 1983.
La Comisión para el Esclarecimiento Histórico
conformada en 1997 determinó que cerca del
90% de todas las violaciones de los derechos
humanos fueron responsabilidad del estado.)
Y, por fin, en 1996, llegó el acuerdo de paz. Sin
embargo, desgraciadamente la violencia no terminó.
De hecho, en 2006 el número de homicidios
fue casi del doble que en 1996,
cuando se firmaron los acuerdos de paz en el país.
Y la pregunta es, ¿cómo es esto posible
que muera más gente en tiempos de paz
que en tiempos de guerra? La razón
se puede resumir en este acrónimo:
CIACS, Cuerpos Ilegales y Aparatos
Clandestinos de Seguridad. Es decir:
organizaciones criminales creadas por el
propio estado para atacar a las guerrillas.
Y, ¿qué hacían exactamente? Pues, en resumidas
cuentas, participar en el narcotráfico,
el contrabando y otras actividades ilegales con
una enorme ventaja: el conocimiento profundo del
Estado. Pensad que muchos de estos grupos
tenían a antiguos generales del ejército,
oficiales de inteligencia y tenían contactos
en las más altas instancias de la política.
Sin embargo, en 2007 hubo un punto de
inflexión Un nuevo sheriff llegó a Guatemala.
Y aquí es cuando llega ese momento donde Guatemala
pudo haber cambiado su curso ¿Qué
pasó? Ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
T2 (UNA COMISIÓN POR LA HONESTIDAD)
Seamos honestos, que nos digan que los
homicidios se han disparado o que alguien
ha sido asesinado en América Latina son
noticias que ya no sorprenden a nadie.
Sin embargo, en 2007 en Guatemala pasó
algo que rompió todos los esquemas, fijaos.
N1 (Asesinan a tres diputados
salvadoreños en Guatemala. 20 minutos)
(Asesinados los policías guatemaltecos
acusados de la muerte de tres diputados
salvadoreños. Un comando armado entra en la
cárcel donde estaban recluidas las víctimas
y las tirotean después de degollarlas. El País)
Efectivamente, queridos amigos de VisualPolitik,
en cuestión de una semana, cuatro
policías guatemaltecos que asesinaron
a tres diputados salvadoreños fueron
a su vez asesinados en la cárcel.
Como os podéis imaginar, estos asesinatos
estaban auspiciados por el propio estado
¿Y quién presionó el gatillo? Pues los
principales sospechosos son las CIACS. Es decir,
estos grupos criminales auspiciados por los
propios servicios de inteligencia del estado.
Pues bien, ESTA fue la gota que colmó
el vaso. A partir de este crimen,
Guatemala se embarcó en un experimento
único en materia de seguridad y derechos:
la Comisión de Investigación Contra la
Impunidad en Guatemala,también conocida
como la CICIG. Quedaos con este nombre porque es
fundamental para entender el resto de la historia.
(Creada por un acuerdo entre Guatemala
y la ONU en diciembre de 2006,
la importancia de la CICIG quedó
expuesta tras los asesinatos de los
diputados salvadoreños y los policías
asesinados en la cárcel en 2007.
Formada como una especie de fiscalía, su cúpula
era elegida por el secretario general de la ONU
y tenía una autonomía casi absoluta. De hecho, la
Comisión recaudaba sus propios fondos para evitar
la interferencia de las autoridades de Guatemala.
No obstante, sus poderes estaban limitados, ya que
tenía que colaborar con el Ministerio Público
y la Fiscalía Especial Contra la Impunidad,
y los casos que presentaba eran sometidos
al sistema de justicia guatemalteco,
que decidía en última instancia si
estos eran o no juzgados. Sin embargo,
la CICIG sí fue capaz de promover la
aprobación de leyes como la Ley del
Crimen Organizado o las que permitían
escuchas telefónicas de sospechosos.)
Durante los primeros años de existencia, la CICIG
actuó como se espera que actúe cualquier cosa que
lleva la palabra “COMISIÓN” en el nombre.
Vamos, que no pusieron a los criminales en
ningún aprieto importante. Esto fue así… hasta
el año 2014 ¿Qué paso en ese momento? Pues que
la CICIG eligió a un nuevo comisionado: IVÁN
VELÁSQUEZ. Para los colombianos que veáis este
vídeo… ¡Sí! Hablamos de ESE Iván Velázquez.
El que ahora es vuestro ministro de defensa.
Y, ¿qué hizo Velásquez para dar
un verdadero impulso a la CICIG?
darse cuenta de que el enemigo
estaba DENTRO del propio sistema.
Las CIACS campaban a sus anchas por Guatemala
porque tenían tentáculos dentro de las propias
instituciones guatemaltecas. Y por eso, si
querían acabar con ellas, había que poner
el foco en la lucha contra la corrupción. Y,
mis queridos amigos de VisualPolitik, aquí
SÍ empezó a incomodar a mucha gente importante en
Guatemala ¿Queréis un ejemplo? ¡Os doy un ejemplo!
Una de las mayores tramas de
corrupción en la historia del país:
el caso de “La Línea”. Se trata de una trama de
corrupción aduanera detectada en 2015 que ha
tenido repercusiones hasta finales del 2022:
N3 (Guatemala / 16 años de prisión para el
expresidente Pérez por delitos de corrupción. El
expresidente de Guatemala, Otto Pérez Molina, ha
sido condenado a 16 años de prisión y una multa de
un millón de dólares por delitos de corrupción.
Pérez está en prisión desde 2015, acusado de
liderar una red de defraudación aduanera en
el caso conocido como La Línea. Euronews)
Y no solo eso, su exvicepresidenta,
Roxana Baldetti, también fue sentenciada
el pasado diciembre a la misma
condena por los mismos cargos.
Pero Velásquez no se detuvo ahí. Después de
darse cuenta de lo tremendamente enredadas
que estaban las redes de corrupción, su
siguiente objetivo fue Jimmy Morales. Y
diréis ¿Quién es este hombre? Pues nada
menos que el PRESIDENTE de Guatemala
por aquel entonces. Presidente hasta el
año 2020 ¡Y vaya si encontraron casos!
Lo primero, un caso menor de corrupción en
los que el hermano y el hijo del presidente
estaban involucrados. Pero, eso fue solo
el comienzo, aún más importante fue el caso
de financiación ilegal del partido Frente de
Convergencia Nacional cuando Morales aún era
su secretario general y era también el
candidato presidencia por esa plataforma.
Y ya sé lo que estaréis pensando
muchos: un aplauso al señor VELASQUEZ
y la CICIG ¿Verdad? Fueron el auténtico
látigo de los corruptos. Pues… sí,
tenéis razón. Pero incomodar a los poderosos
tiene un problema: a los poderosos no les gusta
que les incomoden. Al presidente Morales no
le hizo la más mínima gracia que aparecieran
todos esos escándalos de corrupción. Y
ese fue el principio del fin de la CICIG.
(Tras ser acusado de financiar ilegalmente
su campaña a la presidencia, Morales no
tardó en tomar represalias contra la CICIG. La
presidencia le retiró el apoyo a la Comisión
que tanto estaba siendo alabada por la comunidad
internacional: el Ministerio de la Gobernación,
la Procuraduría y otras instituciones y
organismos que habían estado colaborando
con la CICIG dejaron de respaldarla. De hecho,
incluso se le vetó la entrada al comisionado
Velásquez después de que este saliera del país
en un viaje oficial. Finalmente, el presidente
Morales se negó a revalidar el mandato de la
CICIG, lo que llevó a su disolución en 2019.)
¡Habéis oído bien! La CICIG murió pese a que el
70% de los guatemaltecos la apoyaban. De hecho,
la disolución de esta comisión resonó en
toda la comunidad internacional. Atentos.
C1 (“La decisión unilateral del presidente
Jimmy Morales de dar por terminado en un
plazo de 24 horas el Acuerdo de creación de la
CICIG anunciada en Nueva York por la Ministra
Jovel, es una señal más del progresivo
rompimiento institucional y el Estado de
Derecho” – Rigoberta Menchú, guatemalteca
Premio Nobel de la Paz de 1992, 2019.)
Sin embargo, muchas otras voces festejaron
la decisión del presidente al considerar que
la CICIG se había extralimitado en sus funciones
y que Guatemala estaba perdiendo su soberanía.
C2 (“La CICIG se fue apoderando del sistema
de justicia (…) y la poca confianza que había
en los jueces desapareció por culpa de
la CICIG” – José Luis González Dubón,
miembro de la Liga Pro Patria de Guatemala, 2019.)
Sea como sea, ya estuvieran a favor o en contra de
la CICIG, los guatemaltecos se enfrentaban a una
nueva realidad: una Guatemala sin CICIG después
de 12 años en los que se dejó en evidencia el gran
entramado corrupto en el que viven buena parte
de la clase política y empresarial del país.
Y, como os podéis imaginar, sin esta
comisión, los corruptos volvieron a sus
prácticas habituales con total impunidad.
Guatemala volvió a ser Guatepeor. Y os
preguntaréis ¿En qué estado se encuentran en
estos momentos? Pues ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
Atentos.
T3 (RETOMANDO VIEJOS HÁBITOS)
Si algo nos han enseñado estos últimos 4 años
que Guatemala ha estado sin la CICIG es que los
avances en la lucha contra la corrupción
pueden desvanecerse en un abrir y cerrar
de ojos. En 2019, los guatemaltecos eligieron
al sucesor del ya entonces impopular Morales,
Alejandro Giammattei, como nuevo
presidente de la República.
¿Y qué ha hecho este hombre? Pues ha
iniciado una persecución contra muchos
de los jueces y fiscales que lucharon
contra la corrupción durante la CICIG.
(Esta persecución tiene un
protagonista: Rafael Curruchiche,
actual jefe de la Fiscalía Especial contra
la Impunidad del Ministerio Público,
fue designado por la Fiscal General, Consuelo
Porras, que a su vez le debe su revalidación
en el puesto a Giammattei, a la que Estados
Unidos ha señalado como un “actor corrupto”.
Curruchiche, que lo primero que hizo fue archivar
las investigaciones abiertas contra Giammattei, se
lanzó en tromba a perseguir a los investigadores
de la CICIG y de la propia fiscalía que habían
abierto casos contra políticos y empresarios del
país. Por ejemplo, Curruchiche anunció órdenes
de captura contra Thelma Aldana, exfiscal
general y una de las juristas más reconocidas
contra la corrupción que vive hoy en el
exilio; o también contra David Gaitán,
exfuncionario de la CICIG que trabaja hoy con
la ONG Transparencia Internacional. De hecho,
a finales de mayo del presente año 2023
capturaron al fiscal Stuardo Campo, exjefe
de la Fiscalía Anticorrupción que persiguió por la
vía penal al expresidente Morales y que investigó
a diferentes ministros del Gobierno y a jueces
involucrados en diferentes casos de corrupción.)
Pero ¡ojo! No solo ha perseguido a fiscales
y jueces, la prensa también ha
sido víctima de esta venganza:
N4 (Persecución contra la prensa: “elPeriódico”
de Guatemala anuncia su cierre ante el acoso
del Gobierno. El fundador de la
publicación, José Rubén Zamora,
lleva casi 10 meses en prisión después de décadas
denunciando casos de corrupción estatal. El País)
Por lo que vemos, el odio hacia los medios
de comunicación en Centroamérica no entiende
de ideologías. Bukele, en El Salvador, puso al
periódico “El Faro” en su punto de mira. Ortega,
en Nicaragua, que es de izquierdas, ha hecho lo
mismo con el periódico “La Prensa”. Pues bien,
GIAMMATTEI, que es de ideología
conservadora también tiene a un
periódico en la diana, en
este caso es “ElPeriódico”.
¿Conclusión? Solo entre 2018 y 2023,
30 personas, entre las que hay jueces,
fiscales y periodistas, han
tenido que huir del país.
Y, bueno, uno podría decir: “mientras puedan vivir
bien… ¿Qué más da que haya corrupción?”. Pues,
si sois veteranos seguidores de VisualPolitik
ya sabéis lo que vamos a decir ahora:
el desarrollo de un país está ligado a la calidad
de sus instituciones. En otras palabras: que un
país corrupto tiene todas las papeletas para ser
pobre. Y el caso de Guatemala no es una excepción.
Para que os hagáis una idea, en 2020 el
59% de los 17 millones de guatemaltecos se
encontraban en situación de pobreza, y en 2023
apenas se espera que se reduzca hasta el 55%.
Además, como podéis ver, esta pobreza pega
mucho más duro a las comunidades indígenas
y a las campesinas, que también suelen
estar dominadas por los propios indígenas.
Y, es más, la pobreza es tal que, según el
Banco Mundial, el 47% de todos los niños
menores de 5 años sufren de desnutrición. Y,
os estaréis preguntando, ¿cómo puede ser que
todo esto sea posible? Pues bien, la mayoría de
los analistas lo suelen achacar a tres factores:
En primer lugar, el acceso a la tierra. Ya desde
el siglo XIX, con el boom de la producción de
café en el país, se desarrollaron una serie de
leyes sobre la propiedad de las tierras. Estas
leyes llevaron a una expropiación masiva
de las tierras comunales que pertenecían a
pueblos indígenas ¡Pero no sólo eso! En Guatemala
todavía sobrevive una práctica colonial donde los
campesinos no cobran un sueldo ¡Habéis oído
bien! Muchos grandes terratenientes no pagan
en dinero sino que le dan una pequeña parcela de
tierra al campesino para que pueda cultivarla y
sobrevivir. De esta forma, el campesino no tiene
alternativas para intentar cambiar de vida.
Sin embargo, otros analistas se
centran más en el Estado guatemalteco,
a su reducido tamaño y a la
pobre recaudación tributaria.
De hecho, Guatemala es el tercer país que
menores impuestos recauda de toda la región,
solo después de Panamá y Paraguay. Y diréis
¿Es Guatemala un paraíso fiscal? ¡Para nada!
¡Ya les gustaría! El problema en Guatemala
no se que tengan impuestos bajos sino que no
saben cómo recaudarlos ¿Por qué? Dos
razones: incompetencia y corrupción.
En cualquier caso… ¿Realmente cambiaría
algo si recaudasen más? Probablemente no.
Recordad que hablamos de un país
absurdamente corrupto. Es decir,
que poco de ese dinero iría a
pagar escuelas y carreteras.
Dicho de otra forma: Guatemala es un
país que parece condenado a la pobreza
por culpa de las élites políticas que
lo gobiernan. Tuvo una oportunidad de
romper con esta lógica pero sus propios
políticos hicieron todo lo posible por
arruinarla. Y es difícil pensar que
unas elecciones vayan a cambiar nada.
Pero dicho esto la pregunta
es para todos vosotros:
¿Qué creéis que le hace falta a Guatemala
para poder atacar la corrupción? ¿Llegará a
organizar otra comisión como la CICIG
si la situación se vuelve aún más
insostenible? ¿Tiene futuro GuatemalaHay alguna
razón para tener algo de esperanza en este país?
Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios. Como siempre, no olvidéis que aquí
en VisualPolitik sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las
semanas así que suscribíos a este canal y dadle a
la campanita para no perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones. Si os ha gustado este vídeo,
dadle a LIKE y nos vemos en el
próximo. Un saludo y hasta pronto.